[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome all of you.
My name is Joaquin Ruiz.
I'm the dean of the
College of Science.
And I thank you all
for coming tonight.
[APPLAUSE]
We started this lecture
series five years ago,
more or less, with a
lecture on evolution.
It was a time when Kansas
and parts of the country
were debating whether we should
be teaching intelligent design.
We decided in the
College of Science
that it was important not only
to teach our own students,
but to try to teach
our community what
we knew about science.
And it was a great time.
We started with very few
people, and today we're
turning people away.
Thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Last year's lecture series dealt
with the magic of our brain
and how we think and how
we perceive our universe.
And I think it's
fitting that this year,
we continue with how we
perceive our universe
in a very different way.
Today we're going to talk about
cosmology, how our universe was
created, the origin of
matter, the evolution of time,
the evolution of dark matter,
the evolution of mass.
Really it comes-- it boils
down to really the nitty gritty
of what we we're all about.
And today I am pleased to
first and foremost, thank
all of those that
make this possible.
The lecture series is
not a cheap endeavor,
and people in our community
have really come up
and supported us in it.
The Arizona Daily Star, Cox
Communications, Bob Davis
and Innovation Park,
Galileo Circle--
which are friends of
the College of Science--
Godat Design, Raytheon,
Research Corporation
for Science Advancement,
UniSource Energy
and Ventana Medical have paid
for this, and I thank you all.
Last year, we asked
all of you what
would be an exciting lecture
series for this year.
And many of you did respond
by email of your interests,
and I guess we got it right.
And the interest was cosmology,
and we've done cosmology.
And today I'm as close
to God as I have ever
been, with Guy here,
who's come and given
a lecture about cosmology.
Let me tell you a little bit
about Brother Guy Consolmagno.
He's actually an alumni of
the University of Arizona.
He was the fourth student
that came out of the planetary
Sciences Department--
which we're
so proud of, right-- which
came out of the Sputnik area.
So Guy is the
fourth, and obviously
one of the most extraordinary
students that we've had.
He's been in the Vatican
Observatory since 1993.
His research
explores connections
between meteorites
asteroids and the evolution
of small solar system bodies.
With the Vatican 1.8 metered
advanced technology telescopes,
he surveys the broadband colors
and light curves of Kuiper belt
objects, using these
data to develop
an understanding of
their composition
and internal structures.
Guy is truly an
amazing individual.
He earned his undergraduate
and masters degree at MIT.
He came to the U of A--
to a much better place--
to study planetary sciences.
He arrived the second year that
the department was actually
open.
And as I said before, he was
the fourth graduate student
out of the place.
He's been a researcher
at Harvard and MIT,
served the Peace Corps in
Kenya, and taught physics
at Lafayette College
in Pennsylvania,
before deciding that the
whole thing was a mess.
And he entered the
Jesuit order in 1989.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't know how
many of you saw Guy,
but he actually was
on The Colbert Report.
And he's the only
individual I've
seen in The Colbert
Report that actually
had Colbert speechless, so
that's a feat in itself.
He is a multifaceted scientist,
and I want to welcome--
I want to ask you to welcome
him as our first speaker
in this extraordinary series.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
It's fantastic to be back here.
I think the only other time
I was ever in Centennial Hall
was to hear the Preservation
Hall Jazz Band in 1977.
And I understand they're
coming back here.
I wonder if it's the same guys.
[LAUGHTER]
Tonight as you probably
know is the first
of six lectures on cosmology.
And you've got a
wonderful group of experts
coming in and talking
about everything
from the Big Bang to dark
energy to the origin of life.
By contrast my expertise
is not cosmology.
It's actually the
study of meteorites.
And this was probably
the only time
I get to mention
meteorites tonight.
My role is a little
bit different
from the other speakers.
I'm here to give
you an introduction
to the topic of
cosmology itself,
as someone who is an outsider,
albeit a close outsider.
Most of the speakers here have
been close friends of mine
for years.
Michael Turner,
actually, was the one
who taught me
general relativity,
back at the University
of Chicago 20 years ago.
And so what I want
to do is show you,
with some historical examples,
with a few stories, what
cosmology is, and
why it's interesting.
In fact, why it matters.
Now, I haven't
gotten that reaction.
I probably shouldn't
mention the one connection,
that the Jesuits
have with cosmology.
We're both worried
about missing mass.
But since I'm standing up
here in a clerical collar,
I do want to start
with tonight's lecture
with some readings
from Saint Paul.
The first Paul's letter
to Timothy has in it,
there is one God.
There is also one
mediator between God
and humankind, Jesus
Christ, himself human
who gave himself as
a ransom for this,
and who was attested
to at the right time.
And then in Paul's
letter to the Ephesians
we read, God put this
power to work in Christ,
when he raised
him from the dead,
and seated him at his right
hand in the heavenly places,
far above all rule and authority
and power and dominion,
above every name that is
named, not only in this age,
but in the age to come.
And he goes on to say, you were
dead through the trespasses
and sins in which he
once lived, following
the course of this
world, following
the ruler of the power
of the air or the spirit,
now at work among those
who are disobedient.
And in his letter
to the Colossians,
Paul says of Jesus that he is
the image of the unseen God,
the first born of all creation.
In him we're created,
all things in heaven
and on Earth, everything
visible, everything invisible,
thrones, ruling forces,
sovereignties, powers.
All things were created
through him and for him.
Now, one of the
remarkable things
about the letters of Saint
Paul, especially if you ever
hear them in church on Sunday,
is how utterly forgettable
they are.
You see these words
whooshing past you.
And you go, that sounds all very
nice, but what was that again?
What was he talking about?
If you're lucky, you might
catch a couple of key words
that only caught your
attention, because you
had no idea what he was
talking about, like mediator.
What's this Jesus as mediator?
Why do I need a mediator?
You pray to God.
God prays back or doesn't.
The heavenly places--
what heavenly places?
Far above rule and authority
and power and dominion, thrones,
ruling forces, sovereignties,
the ruler of the power
of the air--
what the heck is
he talking about?
What he's talking
about is cosmology.
Paul was assuming that his
readers and he were sharing
a common cosmology,
that used these terms
and knew what these
terms were all about.
Now, most of us are familiar
with the classical view
of the universe, with
the Earth at the center,
and all the planets going, and
the sun going around the Earth.
When you hear it
described that way,
you're probably thinking
of the Earth at the center,
with that little blue
ball that we've all seen,
and then moon with its
craters whizzing by,
and Saturn with its
rings whizzing by,
and Jupiter with its
moons whizzing by.
No, that's not what this
picture is talking about.
Cosmology is more than just
how the pieces are assembled.
It's about the very nature
of the pieces themselves.
Now, cosmology comes
from Greek words.
It means words
about the universe.
It was a term coined by the
17th century German philosopher,
Christian Wolff.
And he wanted to describe
a kind of metaphysics
that talked about the totality
of everything that existed,
or the nature of the universe,
based on logic and reason.
It was the 17th century.
They were big in logic
and reason in those days.
More generally,
it's a word we can
use to refer to the world
picture of a culture, a school
of thought.
And so in that sense
a cosmology is the sum
of all the assumptions you make,
about how the universe works.
Some of those are assumptions
that you've sat down
and said, yes, I'm
going to assume this.
And some of those are
assumptions that you didn't
even know you were making.
Because they're so built
into the culture, so built
into the way you were raised,
so built into the language
that you use, that
you don't even
appreciate how those
assumptions have colored,
but not only the answers
you come up with,
but the actual-- the questions
you even decide to ask.
In the early 20th century, after
the advent of quantum physics
and Einstein's
theory of relativity,
the word cosmology was taken
over by the astronomers.
And so, nowadays, it represents
the scientific description
of the origin and nature
of the physical universe.
But a cosmology can be
outlined in a way that
doesn't rely necessarily
on physics or astronomy.
And these non-physics
cosmologies
have played important
roles in the development
of human thought, in the
way we understand ourselves.
And there's this
constant feedback
between the assumptions we
make about what the universe is
about, and the science
we decide to do,
the literature we
decide to write,
the art we decide to make.
Ancient cosmologies started
with the observation
that the world was flat.
Go outside.
You can see the world was flat.
There's a dome.
You can go out and see the dome.
Obviously, there must be
things above the dome,
where you're hiding the hail
and the snow and the rain,
because it leaks
through the holes.
Because that's
where it comes from.
Underneath the ground
is fire and brimstone.
You don't believe me?
I can show you a volcano.
You can show the
fire and brimstone.
It's there.
Anybody can see it.
And there are waters
underneath the Earth,
because that's where the water
goes after it stops raining.
There are a lot of
different cultures
who have come up with
a similar picture.
And in many cases, they've
even developed the picture,
so that each of
those things that you
see crossing across the
sky, wandering through,
are themselves their own skies.
There are different
levels of sky.
There is one sky for the moon.
There's another sky for
each of the planets.
There's another sky for the sun.
I was remembering I was
giving a talk on meteorites
to a group of Native Americans
in northern Wisconsin.
And I was trying to describe,
what is a meteorite?
Well, a meteorite is a rock
that falls from the sky.
And an older woman raises
her hand, and she says,
pardon me, which sky?
And I'm thinking, wow, that's
the question that Aristotle
or Thomas Aquinas
might have asked,
because it's out
of that cosmology.
In a sense it's like saying,
which planet does it come from?
But, actually, it's
different, because there's not
thinking of planets
as places, the way
that we're used to
thinking of them.
They're thinking of
them as realms of sky.
Now, determining the
shape of the universe
from observation and reason,
began with the Greeks--
Parmenides, Pythagoras, Plato.
All of them understood by
around the fifth century BC
that the world was round,
that the planets, the moon,
and the sun were other
bodies, traveling somewhere
between the Earth and the stars.
In one of his dialogues,
Timaeus, Plato
discusses whether
or not the universe
was always in existence, or
whether it had a starting
point.
He argues that all things are
in the process of continually
being created.
And that's in opposition
to what Parmenides said,
who said that all
matter was eternal.
But the point is they
were already arguing
these points 500 years BC.
The Pythagorean
mathematician, Eudoxus,
explained the motions of the
planets, which are not simply
going past the stars, but
sometimes wander back,
and then sometimes go forward.
He described them in terms of
a series of concentric spheres
that were crystalline,
that would rotate on axes,
that themselves would rotate.
So it was a very complicated
set of nested spheres.
But out of this he could
explain what anyone with eyes
could see.
Aristotle, of course,
took this and adapted it
to his physical universe.
And he had the
notion that things
in the universe, the
material that you and I are
familiar with, are
made of four elements--
Earth, water, air, and fire.
And one of the natures
of these objects
was that they would try to
travel to their natural place,
so that Earth, the brown
stuff, is at the center,
water is outside
of the brown stuff,
air is outside of
the water, fire
is outside of-- because that's
why the fire element in a flame
is always going
upwards, so that if you
were to travel from the Earth
to the sphere of the moon,
you would wind up traveling
through a ring of fire.
Now, since there's only
one natural resting place
for Earth, obviously,
by necessity
there's only one Earth.
And by necessity, there is
therefore only one universe.
About 400 years after Aristotle,
the Roman era astronomer,
Ptolemy, used the observations
of the Babylonians
and the Greeks to flesh out
this geocentric cosmology.
With mathematical rigor
he was able to work out
the idea of these
little epi-circles.
I'm told there's a
laser pointer here.
Yeah, this-- right, so
that you have Mercury
traveling around the Earth.
But Mercury itself is also
traveling in little circles.
In order to explain why,
when you observe Mercury,
sometimes it goes back.
And likewise all of
the planets traveling
around circles, which are not
exactly centered on the Earth--
because these circles have to
be a little bit off center,
in order to actually
match the observed
motions of the planets.
But the thing was--
it worked.
It worked to within the
limits of their observations.
Mathematically he was able
to demonstrate the accuracy
of this geocentric cosmology.
You've got a theory.
You've got observations.
The observations
match the theory.
Hey, it's good science.
It must be true.
That's the assumption
that science
has worked on all along.
And so this was accepted
for another 1,000 years.
Now, the Ptolemaic
system was a long cry
from that biblical version,
of a flat Earth with a dome
and water above and below.
Saint Augustine knew that.
Writing well after Ptolemy
had been established,
he wrote a book
called On the Literal
Interpretation of Genesis.
And he warned his
fellow Christians.
He says, even a
non-Christian knows something
about the Earth, the heavens,
and the other elements
of the world, about the motion
and the orbits of the stars,
even about their sizes
and relative positions.
Because Ptolemy was
able to work out that
the stars were very far away.
The planets were
very far away, using
the geometry
available to him, even
with naked-eye observations.
And this was well-known
throughout the world,
throughout the educated world.
This knowledge and
educated person has--
Augustine goes on, this
knowledge and educated person
holds as being certain from
reason and from experience.
And he concludes it is a
disgraceful and dangerous thing
when an infidel--
here's a Christian
presumably giving
the meaning of Holy
Scripture, talking nonsense
about these things.
It's clear that he
had his literalists.
But it's also clear that
the educated Christians
understood, that's not how
you interpret scripture.
Of course, one of the ironies
is that the sure knowledge
of a science, that
he's talking about,
was the Ptolemaic system
that we now know is nonsense.
And so rather than this conflict
between the Ptolemaic system
and the biblical system leading
to some kind of Galileo trial
in the Early Middle Ages,
what really happened
was that most
theologians, at that time
and through the Middle Ages,
saw in this Ptolemaic cosmology
a reflection of the
nonphysical universe.
Even if you assume
a spherical Earth,
you still have this idea
that the physical universe
is a mirror of the
metaphysical universe.
And if you had that picture
of the Earth at the center,
and the planets going
around the Earth, that
doesn't mean the Earth is
the most important part.
No, the Earth is
not at the center.
It is at the bottom of
the chain of creation.
The only thing lower
is the inferno,
that fire and brimstone
I was talking about.
And it's only after you get
past the lunarian sphere,
that you finally
get to the realm,
where things move eternally
in perfect circular motion.
So it was not
self-centeredness that
said the Earth was the
center of the universe.
It was a kind of
degradation that said,
the Earth is the
bottom of the universe.
And, in fact, there are those
writing in the Middle Ages
who make the point
that we, human beings,
are seeing the entire
universe inside out.
The way that it
really works, you see,
is that there's God
we see at the outside.
Because of a love of
God, the stars move--
literally moved by
love to try to imitate
the perfection of God, by
spinning at a constant rate.
And their spin, in turn,
influences the inner spheres
to spin.
And so this influence travels
down from sphere to sphere
to sphere, until you get to
the translunarian sphere.
But, of course, these
influences continue
on to the astrology that
influences our lives on Earth.
That was the chain they saw.
But that chain is obviously
inverted from reality,
because God is the center.
And we are the ones
that are on the outside,
so far out that we're
barely noticeable.
That was the medieval cosmology.
A great source for this
kind of information,
if you want to look up
further, is a wonderful book
by C.S. Lewis called
The Discarded Image.
Now, everybody knows
C.S. Lewis is the guy who
wrote the Narnia books.
You forget he had a day job.
And his day job was
being a professor
of Renaissance and medieval
literature at Oxford.
And he wrote this based on a
series of lectures he gave,
so that his students would
be able to understand
medieval literature, which
itself assumed this cosmology.
You can't read Dante
without reading this stuff.
You can't read Chaucer without
understanding the cosmology,
that Chaucer thought
described the universe.
And so to quote from
The Discarded Image,
"The spheres are moved
by the love of God.
Each sphere or something
resident in the sphere
is a conscious and
intellectual being, moved
by intellectual love of God.
The planetary intelligences
make a very small part
of the angelic
population, which inhabits
the vast aetherial
region, especially
the region between the
moon and the Primum Mobile,
so that from the
Earth, from the moon
on out to where you find God.
Those regions are called
thrones, dominations,
et cetera."
Remember where we
heard those terms?
"Below the moon is the
realm of aerial beings,
which are known as demons.
In some sources the
demons can be good or bad.
Other sources divide
the good demons
into the upper air and the
bad demons in the lower air.
By the time of the Middle
Ages," Lewis tells us,
"the view gained ground
that all demons were bad."
In fact, they were
the fallen angels.
And that's where D-A-E-M-O-N
became D-E-M-O-N.
And this is just the
beginning of a census of all
of the strange and
marvelous creatures,
that people assumed existed,
that we only see the faintest
reflection in modern fantasies,
like Lord of the Rings.
All of the different
kinds of creatures you
see in Lord of the Rings were--
Tolkien was a scholar
reflecting this medieval view
of the universe.
And, in fact, this view of
the universe, this cosmology,
was a beautiful system.
And it underlaid not only
the physics and astronomy
of the day, it
provided the framework
for the literature of the day--
Chaucer and Dante.
It provided the framework
for the artwork of the day.
To quote Lewis, again,
"There are few constructions
of the imagination
to have combined
such splendor, sobriety, and
coherence to the same degree."
He then goes on to write,
"It may be possible
that some readers have long
been itching to remind me,
that it did have
a serious defect."
It wasn't true, but
it sure was beautiful.
And this was the point
of Paul's letters,
the things that I read
in the first place.
Brian Purfield who is writing
for the British Jesuit
website, Thinking Faith,
interprets Paul's letters
as a reaction against
the cosmology.
And I'm going to
quote him again.
The people in Ephesus,
the people in Colossae
already had a view of the
world and their place in it.
According to their
world view, the gods
were up there in the sky.
The people were
down here on Earth.
Between the gods and
themselves were a whole host
of intermediaries-- the demons.
And if you're going to live
a happy life down here,
you've got to keep those
intermediaries happy.
Because each of
them is in charge
of some part of
your earthly life.
Now, Paul had gotten
word from Colossae
that the people there
were adopting Christianity
to their culture.
And so when the
gospel preached to--
Colossians says that
Jesus is their mediator.
They said, well, we
already have mediators.
We've already got these
demons doing the mediating.
What do we need Jesus for?
Or, at the very least, how
does Jesus fit into the system?
Is he like the super mediator?
In other words, they were
trying to take the gospel,
and superimpose it on their
already existing world view.
And Paul doesn't
want them to do that.
But, of course, as you can
see, it's a hopeless case.
It's such an all-encompassing
world view, that they could not
conceive of life, religion,
living without assuming well,
of course, there's demons.
How else do you expect?
You don't believe in the gods?
I can point them to you up in
the sky moving back and forth.
Anybody can see
them for themselves.
Meanwhile, back in India, we
have a very different cosmology
and a very different
take on things.
Around the year 500,
Aryabhata was this marvelous
mathematician and astronomer.
And in India at that time they
had not only phenomenally good
mathematics, but
they had the benefit
of having had the
Greeks around a few
100 years earlier,
who had brought them
all of the observational
evidence of the Babylonians.
So they had about 1,000
years worth of observations
of the planets.
And Aryabhata
around the year 500
has this radical idea,
that maybe the reason
we see the stars moving
from night to night,
during the night, is because
the Earth, which everybody
knows is round, is spinning.
He came up with this idea
500 years before Copernicus.
And if it's the Earth
spinning, then it's
the stars that are
standing still.
Then what's really interesting
is, how long does it
take for each of the planets
to move a complete circuit
through the fixed stars?
So we looked
through the records.
And these are the
numbers he comes up with.
He says, for Mercury if
you wait 125 Earth years,
Mercury makes 519 circuits
through the stars.
Venus-- 251 Earth years
gives you 408 Venus years.
On Mars 205 Earth years
gives you 109 planet years.
So put this in a spreadsheet.
Do the division for yourself.
The calculated
period for Mercury
is 0.24 Earth years,
0.61519 Earth years--
1.88073.
These are the modern
accepted periods--
pretty darn good.
Now, I'm only quoting these
out to five decimal places,
for the reason that
it's not that we
don't know the period of Mars
to more than five places.
It's because the period of Mars
is only constant to within five
places.
It actually varies slightly
in the sixth place,
depending on the perturbation
of Jupiter that year.
So that this is as
good as-- accurate
as you're going to get.
You can't do any
better than that.
But Aryabhata is a
Hindu in a culture
that believes that the
universe repeats itself.
And he's in a culture that
has phenomenal mathematics,
but hasn't yet invented
the decimal point.
So he can't make
this calculation.
All he can do is give you
these sets of numbers.
But this divided by that
is a rational number.
And this is actually
an irrational number.
And the difference is only
in the fifth decimal place.
But the difference is enough,
because being of a culture that
expected to find a
repeating universe,
he then takes these numbers
and multiplies them together,
to find the common
denominator, which
would be the amount of time
it takes for the universe
to repeat itself.
And it's a brilliant
calculation.
And it's only off in
the fifth decimal place.
But you can see how his
culture, his cosmology,
has led him to ask a
question we would never ask.
Because we know the planets
don't repeat themselves.
They started arguing.
And his followers
started arguing about,
was there a time when all the
planets were exactly lined up?
And oh, by the way, since
the position of the planet
controls your
astrological horoscope,
this is clearly scientific proof
that not only does the universe
repeat itself, but that every
human action repeats itself,
when we're on this endless
cycle and endless chain--
a very different cosmology
using the same observations,
coming up with a very
different set of conclusions,
based on the questions
you expect to ask,
and the answers that you
think you're looking for.
Now, while this is going on--
skip ahead here
to my cheat sheet.
Too many things in my hand.
I'm going to drop that.
I'm going to say, who
needs those pages?
Get rid of that.
Right.
Yes, I'm going to move ahead
now to the Middle Ages, the year
1000.
By the time of the Middle
Ages-- the High Middle Ages--
most of this Greek
and Roman learning
had been lost to the West.
But it wasn't lost to
the Arabs, and it wasn't
lost in the Islamic world.
There was a little bit of
crossover around the year 990,
980.
There was an enterprising
young French scholar, Gerbert
d'Aurillac--
grew up near the
border of Spain, which
was Islamic in those days.
He traveled to Barcelona.
He'd learned the
secrets of the abacus
and the armillary sphere.
He's the one who introduced
Arabic numerals to the West.
His knowledge was so frightening
that people started rumors
that he was really a sorcerer.
Now, I was looking for a
picture on the internet
of an armillary sphere
and a picture of Gerbert,
and this is what
I came up with--
because, yes, he became
Pope Sylvester II.
He was the one who
introduced Arabic numerals
to the Western world.
And he was the one
that people thought
was a sorcerer, because
he could do mathematics.
What finally happened was
about 100 years later in 1085,
the university in
Toledo, Spain was
captured by Christian forces.
Its library was then
translated into Latin.
And, finally, the
ancient knowledge
was reintroduced into
European universities.
Now, at that time there
were certain aspects
to Aristotle's
thought, that appeared
to be in great conflict
with Christian teaching.
For instance, Aristotle taught
that the universe was eternal.
Genesis says, God
created the universe.
Now, which is it?
In fact, Thomas
Aquinas, by the 1200s,
had worked out a system
that meshed the two.
He did it so well that
within a generation,
people thought that Aristotle
actually was a Christian.
He just didn't know it.
However, the fact that there
were conflicts between theology
and the ancient wisdom inspired
a number of medieval thinkers.
And here are two of them--
Maimonides and Bishop
Nicholas of Cusa.
To look with a critical eye
at the Aristotelian thought,
and to try to develop new ideas,
and to try to expand or alter
the cosmology of Aristotle,
rather than simply glomming it
on wholeheartedly, and assuming
that Christianity could be
built on top of
it, it's sometimes
thought that the
Renaissance would
have happened by around
the mid-1400s, if it hadn't
been for the Black Death.
The plague reduced the
population of Europe
by a third.
And the population
of Europe didn't
recover to where it
was in these years,
until the time of
the Renaissance
that we actually know.
And it's worth
noting that anyone
who tried to develop
an alternate cosmology,
had to face certain
serious scientific ideas.
We know the
Copernican system that
showed the-- explained why Venus
has phases and such things.
Tycho Brahe, the fellow
on the left here,
actually developed a
famous system here,
where the Earth
is at the center.
The moon goes around the Earth.
The sun goes around the Earth.
All the other planets
go around the sun.
And in this way,
he actually had all
of the benefits of
the Copernican system,
without any of
the disadvantages.
For example, Brahe also
measured the positions
of stars very carefully,
and was able to show
no parallax, no little dodging
of the stars back and forth,
from one time of the year,
to another time of the year,
thus proving the
Earth doesn't move.
In fact, there is a marvelous
thing that has just come out--
a fellow named Graney who's
doing history of science.
If you wanted to show whether
or not there was parallax,
as the Earth moves,
shouldn't you
see the relative positions
of the stars shift about?
To do that you would
want two stars that
were really close to each other,
but one much closer to you
than the other, so that if you
move your head back and forth--
my head moves differently
from how the screen moves.
Because I'm in a
different position,
and that's how you know
that actually you're moving.
Well, what you need are
two stars of very different
brightness, so that, obviously,
the brighter star is closer
to you, and the dimmer
star is further away,
that are real close
to each other.
Galileo observed Mizar,
the easiest double star.
And he observed
it very carefully
over a period of two years,
looking for such a motion.
Because rather
than understanding
that Mizar is a dim star,
orbiting a bright star,
he thought it was two
stars that just happened
to be in the same line--
an optical double,
but one further away.
He was unable, obviously, to see
such a motion, which disproved
the Copernican system.
So like a good
scientist, he never
bothered to publish his results.
But the real story I
want to talk about here,
the story of cosmology,
is not the story
of Brahe so much, but the story
of the fellow next to him,
Johannes Kepler.
Kepler, basically,
inherited Brahe's data.
But he also had along with this
wonderfully precise description
of the positions of
the planets over time,
which Brahe's system more
or less is able to produce,
he had an interesting
philosophical system.
Now, let's actually look
at the Ptolemaic system
versus the Brahe system, or the
Copernican and the Ptolemaic.
Here you've got the Earth,
and things are going around,
and they've all got
little epicycles.
Copernicus moves the
sun to the center,
and he's got everything
going around the sun.
But, still, the planets
have little epicycles.
And, still, each
of the planets is
orbiting a spot that's not
exactly the center of the sun.
And, in fact, the sun itself is
making a little dodgy circle.
And he needs to do this in order
to preserve the appearances,
in order to actually
accurately predict,
where a planet can be
seen on any given night,
because both of these
systems assume that planets
move in perfect circles.
Now, Kepler had
a different idea.
Kepler's brilliant insight
is that, as we all know,
the physical universe mirrors
the metaphysical universe.
If you're going to put
the sun at the center--
the sun is the most brilliant.
The sun is the most wonderful.
Obviously, the sun
represents God.
But since he's a Christian
and believes in the Trinity,
it's God the Father.
The light that
comes off of the sun
is the Holy Spirit, pouring
off of God the Father.
And when it falls on
the sphere of the Earth,
it's the sphere of the Earth.
That's the second
person of the Trinity.
Now, if the sun is
actually the mirror of God,
it can't be making this stupid
little dance around nothing.
God doesn't do that.
Instead what must
be happening is
that the sun must
be standing still,
and the planets are doing
some other kind of motion.
And the kind of motion that
allows this cosmology to work
is if you assume the planets
are moving in ellipses.
It was on the basis of this
wacko theology, which nobody
at the time but him believed.
But in order to make
the sun look beautiful--
I'm stealing all
of this from a book
by Job Kozhamthadam who taught
me philosophy of science.
Oh, he's got a wonderful
letter in his book.
This is a letter from
Kepler to Herbert von
Hohenburg, "The center is
the origin and the beginning
of the sphere.
Indeed the origin has precedence
everywhere, and by his nature
always the first.
When we apply this consideration
to the most Holy Trinity,
the center must refer to
the image of God the Father.
Hence, the center of this
material world sphere
should be adorned by the most
ornate body that is the sun."
Now, the fact that he had
this ludicrous theology,
meant that nobody really
paid much attention,
to the rest of his astronomy.
He would send these
books to Galileo.
And Galileo would look at
them and say, that nut,
and toss them in the
corner and never read them.
And most other people did that.
The only person
apparently who did
read them was Edmond Halley,
who then told Newton about it.
And that gave rise to Newton's
attempting and succeeding
in using his law of gravity, to
explain the elliptical orbits.
Now, notice a
common trait in all
of the different ways of
putting the universe together,
that we've looked at so far.
Up to a point there is
an unspoken assumption--
an assumption that
nobody even knew
they were making, because it was
so obvious to them, that when
you're talking about
astronomy, you're
also talking about religion.
One tells you how
to go to heaven.
The other tells you
how the heavens go.
That's the famous quote.
Cardinal Baronius said that
in defense of Galileo--
at the time of Galileo--
and it's a marvelous quote,
except that they're still
referring to the same heaven.
The physical and
the metaphysical
really don't divide, until
you get to Isaac Newton.
Now, the physics of
Isaac Newton finally
provided a viable replacement.
Do you recognize what it is?
This is according
to the sign there.
That's the tree planted
by one of the apples, that
hit Isaac Newton in the head.
This is actually in Cambridge.
I got it off the internet.
The new physics of Isaac Newton
provided a viable replacement
for Aristotle's system.
Finally, you not only
had a different way
of describing where
the planets were,
you had a different way of
explaining why the planets were
where they were.
And it relied on
physical laws that
applied exactly the same to
objects in space, as to apples
from trees.
And that was the magic and
remarkable breakthrough,
and the total disrupting
of the old way of thinking
of the universe, into a new way
of thinking of the universe.
The Earth and everything
on it was no longer
at the bottom of creation.
It had been elevated to equality
with the rest of the planets.
And this new way of
looking at the universe
gave rise to an
overt assumption,
one that is carried forth
in all cosmology even today.
There is no privileged
place in the universe.
The laws that
govern the universe
are the same everywhere.
Material is the same everywhere.
And deductions
about the universe
derived in one place
in the universe,
based on observations
from that place,
also ought to be true
in any other place.
And this cosmological
assumption is still
the fundamental
assumption, that underlies
everything you're going to
hear in the next six weeks.
Just as the Earth is one
place among several places,
the sun now becomes one
star among many stars.
And so speculations
about other worlds,
which have been going on
since medieval times--
the medieval idea
of another world
was basically a
parallel universe.
Now, it's simply another star
with other planets going around
it.
Galileo's telescope had shown
that the Milky Way was actually
a collection of
individual stars.
And the lack of
parallax of the stars
shows that the stars
are really far away.
So the stars can't be shining
by reflected sunlight.
They must actually
have their own light.
And then in 1755, Immanuel
Kant, writing in the Universal
Natural History and
Theory of the Heavens,
carries this one step
further and says,
those discs of light that
we see may themselves
be island universes, analogous
to our own Milky Way.
And this discussion-- this
idea was argued vehemently
for the next 200 years.
This is a paper by William
Herschel, where he actually--
that bright star in the center
there represents the sun.
And this is his idea
of the farthest star
he can see in every direction,
away from the sun, based
on his telescope, out
of which he deduces
that we are in a disc of stars.
Of course, he still has
the Earth and the sun
at the center of the disc, but
he has it that we're a disc.
And he realizes that
there are other discs that
may well be other Milky Ways.
As we are used to calling the
appearances of the heavens,
where it is surrounded with
a bright zone, the Milky Way,
it may not be a myth to point
out some other very remarkable
nebulae, which
cannot-- will be less,
but are probably much
larger than our own system.
And being also extended, the
inhabitants of the planets that
attend to the stars, which
compose them must likewise
perceive the same
phenomena, for which reason,
they may also be called Milky
Ways by way of distinction.
This is 1795.
That was the development of
cosmology in the Newtonian era.
And then Einstein comes along.
In 1916, Einstein described
in his general theory
of relativity, how space
and time and matter
are all interrelated,
how the force of gravity
can be understood as a
warping of spacetime.
And then he's got a problem.
Because if gravity is
the warping of space
and the universe is
infinite in space and time,
then given the infinite amount
of time the universe is around,
all of the universe should have
warped itself into one point.
Obviously, it hasn't.
What's going on?
The best Einstein
can come up with is
to find a place
in his equations,
where he can stick a
number, that he's calling
the cosmological constant
just, OK, there's
a fudge factor here that's
keeping the universe separated.
I hate it.
It looks inelegant,
but there it is.
At the same time there
is a Russian, Friedmann,
who has the idea that an
expansion of the universe
could obviate the need for
this cosmological constant.
But it's actually this
guy in the familiar collar
who also has a familiar ring,
because he was an MIT graduate.
But he was not a Jesuit.
He hated being called a Jesuit.
He was a diocesan priest.
He was from Belgium.
His name was Georges Lemaitre.
And he actually had two PhDs.
His first PhD was from Louvain,
and it was in mathematics.
He was fundamentally
a mathematician.
But he did post-doctoral work
with Eddington in Cambridge,
came across the equations
that Einstein used
to describe general relativity.
And being a
mathematician, he could
read the equations of
mathematics, the way
that an English major
can read a poem,
and pull out information,
and see the implications
within the math.
And he says, expansion
is in these equations.
The cosmological constant is
not necessarily a bad idea.
Don't get rid of it.
But expansion is built into it.
You can build an
entire cosmology,
based on the idea of
an expanding universe.
And this fits in, in fact,
with quantum theory, which
is also being developed
at the same time.
What if the universe started
at a point of incredibly
high quantum number, and because
of the energy of this point
is expanding from what
he calls a cosmic seed?
This, of course, means
that the universe
has a starting point in time.
And this guy is a priest.
We know where this is going.
Fred Hoyle, who is another
cosmologist of the era,
made fun of this theory
by referring to it
as this Big Bang theory.
Fred Hoyle was
viciously anti-clerical.
You can picture what would
happen when Fred Hoyle
and Georges Lemaitre meet.
They were best of
friends, actually.
They went on vacations together.
They were good buddies.
They got along great, because
they were both interested
in the same things.
But they came out of
different systems.
To Hoyle, the idea of
a universe that was not
eternal and infinite, was so
contrary to the way he had
been raised as a cosmologist.
Because it says that there
is, if not a particular place
that's special, a particular
time that's special,
that violates the
cosmological principle,
forgetting that the cosmological
principle was after all just
an assumption.
Lemaitre, on the other hand, was
very much at pains to say, no.
Somebody is trying to call me.
How dare they?
No, I'm not coming
up with this as a way
to try to rescue Genesis.
Please don't say that.
It's because it's
in the equations.
You look at the equations.
You can see the same thing.
And, hey, we'll test it.
We'll ask Edwin Hubble.
Does he see galaxies
moving apart or not?
And, of course, he does
see galaxies moving apart.
So Hoyle comes up with
an alternate cosmology--
and you'll get
all of this story.
I'm sure in the next--
the one interesting story
is in 1951, Pope Pius XII--
this is him visiting
our observatory
in about that time--
gave an address to the
Pontifical Academy of Sciences,
which is a group of
about 100 scientists
from around the
world, who were there
to advise the church
on scientific issues.
And they're not all Catholics
and not all believers.
Stephen Hawking is a member
of the Pontifical Academy.
And as addressing
these people he says,
isn't it interesting that
modern cosmology is now talking
about a beginning point?
Cute.
And Lemaitre hears about this.
And he's going, no,
no, don't say that.
You're undoing everything
I've been trying to say.
In 1952, the year
after this account,
the IAU, the International
Astronomical Union,
was scheduled to meet in Rome.
And they had invited the pope
to give some opening remarks.
And, suddenly, the
rumor is going around.
The pope is going to
endorse the Big Bang
theory as Catholic doctrine.
Lemaitre, who, after all,
invented the Big Bang theory
is terrified.
And he goes, and he gets
an audience with the pope,
and he says, please, don't.
And, in fact, if
you actually read
the pope's earlier
statement, it's
very clear that he understands,
no, this is just a curiosity.
I'm not actually saying this
is the way it really happened,
because who knows what
cosmology is going to look
like in a thousand years?
And when it came
time for the pope
to address the people at the
IAU, all he said was, you guys,
I love what you're doing.
Keep it up-- which what more can
you ask a head of state to say?
The point is that
even today people
try to use the Big Bang
theory, either as a proof of,
or a proof against--
Stephen Hawking has a book
that just came out that shows,
oh, I figured out a way that
the gravitational interactions
in a vacuum can actually lead to
the spark that is the Big Bang.
We don't need God anymore.
It just spontaneously occurred.
This cartoon
appeared as a result.
The fact is, of course, that
Stephen Hawking is right,
that using God to explain
all the things that we can't,
whether it's the
start of the universe,
or the motions of the planets,
or why trees grow, reduces God
to a nature God,
reduces God to nothing
more than the God of thunder,
and the God of lightning,
and he's just Zeus, or, at the
very least, one physical force
alongside all the
other physical forces.
And going back to
what Saint Paul was
trying to tell his
followers, that's
not the way to think of God.
You can't tie your religion
to any one cosmology.
But this does have
an interesting twist,
about the nature of
our deeper beliefs,
our culture, and our cosmology.
I love this wonderful
phrase from Chesterton,
"The Earth is so very large.
The cosmos is so very small.
It's about the smallest
hole that a man
can hide his head in."
What is he talking about here?
He's talking about
the Earth, the reality
of our lives, the cosmos as
the ideas we have in our head,
about how the universe
works, compared
to the way the
universe really is.
And what is fascinating is
that the major religions that
have been around
for a long time,
whether it's Christianity,
Judaism, Islam,
the animists, the Hindus--
religions that have survived
a change in cosmology
grow as a result. They
get wiser as a result.
They recognize what
stuff is essential
and what stuff was
just cultural baggage.
Sometimes the way you learn
is to run into somebody
you disagree with vehemently.
It works in science.
You get a paper in the mail,
and you say, that's not right.
That can't be right.
OK, where did he go wrong?
And in working
that out you learn
something, that you never would
have thought about before.
Sometimes recognizing that
the cosmology we're in,
the culture that we're
in, is inadequate,
is a brilliant way of
growing both our own culture,
our own religion,
our own philosophy,
and our cosmologies.
Because one thing I
think you're going
to find all of the
next five speakers
agreeing on, is
that half of what
you're going to hear in the
next five weeks is wrong.
We just don't know which
half yet, but that's OK.
That's what makes it fun.
And rather than being
afraid of a new cosmology,
we have to look at it as an
opportunity to recognize,
how much more wonderful,
and how much more beautiful
this universe is.
And I end with one last
quote from Chesterton,
which I just
stumbled across as I
was putting the
talk together, and I
think gives us that sense
of the proper attitude,
that every scientist has
towards the universe.
He says, "The essence
of all pantheism
is that nature is our mother.
The main point of
Christianity is
that nature is not our mother.
Nature is our sister."
He says, "Nature
was a solemn mother
to the worshippers
of Isis and Cybele,
a solemn mother to
Wordsworth and Emerson.
But to Saint Francis, nature
is a sister and even more,
a younger sister, a
little dancing sister,
to be laughed at
as well as loved."
And that is the attitude
that we can embrace and enjoy
the universe, and our
study of the universe.
Thanks a whole lot for coming.
We'll have a few minutes here
for question and answers.
There are going to be a
few folks walking around
with microphones.
But just in case you don't get
the answers you want today,
Brother Guy is going to be
on astronaut.com tomorrow
at 12:00 noon.
So you can do--
I don't know how to do this,
but you can get on the computer,
and talk to him
through the computer.
It's the new cosmology, I guess.
So just remember that.
Astronaut.com.
So do you see any supernatural
aspect or evidence
to the universe, and,
if so, how would it look
different, absent that aspect?
I think my religion informs my
way of looking at the universe,
but it doesn't define
it or control it.
It rather explains why
I'm interested in looking
in the universe in
the first place.
It doesn't tell me what to do.
It tells me why
I want to do it--
the fact that I find astronomy,
not only rational, but also
fun, that I find
the ability to guess
that this theory is
better than that theory,
because it's more beautiful.
To me, those are reflections
of the nature of the Creator.
And that's very
different from saying,
it must have been this
way, because I know God,
and God would have
done it that way.
That doesn't work.
Because I don't
know God that well.
I can't get away with that.
Excuse me.
I'm just dying to know, what
did you tell the woman--
the Indian woman
who said, which sky?
What did you tell her?
I don't remember-- probably
something like that's
a wonderful question.
It is that I don't
know how to answer it.
And if you were
to ask it today, I
wouldn't know how to answer it.
Here we go.
A fascinating lecture--
what I gather from this
is that you view all
cosmologies as transient.
All of science is
transient, in the fact
that a thousand years from
now, the science books
are going to look real different
from the way they are now.
But where we are now is
a necessary place to be,
to get to where we're going
to be in a thousand years.
Oh, good segue.
I wanted to ask you a question.
Oh, OK, sure.
We'll get to that.
How will we recognize
in the public, us,
people in the audience, when
a new cosmology is rising,
and how do we test it?
In the public it's really hard.
The trouble is that the things
that get reported in the news
are new, and by their
nature, they're uncertain.
People have done
studies of science
as it's covered
in the newspapers.
And it's generally
wildly inaccurate,
not because of any
fault of the reporters,
but because the new
stuff itself turns out
to be wildly inaccurate--
50% wrong, and we didn't
know yet where the 50% was.
So my sense is to allow yourself
to be entertained by new ideas.
But don't sell
your soul to them.
Essentially, it takes about
a generation for an idea
to become well
enough established,
that you can have
some confidence,
that it's a sure stepping
stone to go further.
And science does
proceed rather slowly.
There is a consensus effect
when a lot of scientists
think that we can get
someplace with this.
But there's also the sense
of, does it bear fruit?
Do new, good ideas
come out of it,
that we wouldn't have had
before, that explain things,
maybe we didn't even know
needed explaining before?
And that's why things
like string theory
are so suspect,
because the string
theorists seem to have run into
a brick wall at the moment.
There was a guy in our
community, a Jesuit from Italy,
who's doing string theory.
And he's as
frustrated as anyone.
But it could be-- you want
to give the next breakthrough
around the road.
You don't want to
give up on it yet.
It's still one of the best
things we've got going.
But there are a lot of
places where we're stuck.
This stuff is hard.
One of the things
that I worry about--
and I've mentioned the
unspoken assumptions.
We have a generation.
We have how many generations
of physics students who
have been educated
in our universities,
since the advent of quantum
theory, since the realization
that Newtonian physics
is fundamentally untrue?
And, yet, how do we teach them?
We teach them Newtonian physics.
And there's a lot of
practical reasons.
It allows you to build
bridges that don't fall down.
You can get a job with it.
But when it comes to
trying to understand
the nature of physics
in physical reality,
are we doing our students a
disservice by getting them
to go think in the habit
of Newtonian physics,
when, in fact, maybe those are
the wrong habits to think in?
And, yet, how would you teach
a 17-year-old quantum physics,
without teaching him
Newtonian physics first?
We haven't figured that out yet.
So we've got a long way to go.
And that's why it's so much fun.
Well, thank you very much.
I think that's good.
Great, thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you, very much.
Next week we will
have Chis Impey.
Many of you know
Chris Impey will
be talking about the origin
of the universe, the Big Bang
theory.
And there's also these
papers out there that have
if you fill out--
and you're lucky enough,
we're going to have--
we'll give you a
telescope, actually,
if you are the winner.
So fill it out, and thank you
very much for coming tonight.